字幕: Neeta Bhansali
校正: Mieko Yabiku
若い方の後に こんなおっさんが
出てきてますけれども
同志社中学校の井口と申します
社会科を担当しています
教員生活21年を迎えました
10年前ぐらいから
自分の授業がいまいち
イケてないなという風に思い始めて
改善をしようと思っています
そのきっかけは卒業生たちとの
ある会話の中です
卒業生に「中学校のころの思い出は？」
と聞くと
ほとんどの子たちが クラブや学園祭の
ことは言うんですけれども
授業のことは言ってくれない
「井口の授業どうだった？」って聞いても
「どうだっけ？」って言ってサラッと流されて
ほとんどの授業を忘れてしまっている
ということにドキッとしました
「これでいいんかな？」って
やっぱり記憶に残して欲しいって思うんです
教師って子供たちの記憶に残る授業を
本当にしてるやろうかって
日々考えるべきだと思います
では 「どんな授業をすれば
子供たちの記憶に残るか」っていうことで
悶々としていたんですけれども
４〜５年前あたりから
「アクティブラーニング」なんていうことが
よく言われるようになりました
「アクティブラーニングって凄いな」
と思う部分は確かにあります
学びのスタイルは多様になったし
バリエーションが沢山沢山増えていった
だから子供たち自身の中にも
あ 自分に合った勉強のスタイルはこうだとか
私はこれはちょっと苦手だなとか
積極的に学びのスタイルについて
アピールするような子たちが出てきました
こうしたことを受けて僕自身も
例えば ポスターセッションをやったり
あるいは発表をやったりして
子供たち同士が学び合ったり
教え合うというようなことをやってみたんですね
いい表情で喋りましたから
これは一定成功だなと思います
いくつかだけ紹介しようと思います
あまり時間がありませんので
早口になるかもしれませんが
例えば ある男の子たちのグループが
就職難ということをテーマに話し合います
あ 発表したんですね
で 街中へ出て行って就活をしてなんか
暗い顔してはる人をわざわざ見つけてきて
「あんたどんな仕事をやろうとしているの？
大丈夫？」みたいにして
中学生が言っていくわけです
怖いもの知らずで怖いですね 本当に
中に 女の子で深刻そうな顔をして
インタビューしたら
１時間も捕まっちゃったとかいって
言ってたんですけど
その子たちから聞いた内容で
作ったのがこのビニール傘
まあ ちょっとよく見てください
面白いんですよ
エントリーシートを何個か送るけれども
全部いらないと落とされる
書類選考で落とされて 落ち込んで就活を嫌になる
ますます受かりにくくなる
危機意識で どんどんどんどん
何社でも受けようとすると
その会社に受かりたいという熱意が
生まれなくなっていく
だから 会社側からも
その情熱を感じられないということで
また面接で失敗する
「悪魔のサイクルだ」とか言うて
これ回すわけです
(笑)
だから こういうことやられると
専門で中学の教師している僕なんか
太刀打ちできないわけですよ
どひゃどひゃと子供たちが盛り上がって
結局僕の授業より こないだの授業の方が
覚えているということになるわけです
で こんな風に教室の中で発表しただけじゃなくて
さらに 突き抜けた子たちが出てきました
例えば この放置自転車を無くそう なんていうことを
取り組んだ女の子たち
高槻商店街には 1000台を超える
放置自転車があって
商店街の皆さんが困っているということを
聞きつけたから
「何とかしてその放置自転車を
無くそうという取り組みをさせてください」
と言って どんどんどんどん押しかけたんですね
ところが 商店街の事務局の方々は
「いやちょっと勘弁して」って言う
「え ポスター貼らせてください」
「ダメ」
「チラシ配らせてください」
「音楽かけてアピールさせてもらって
歌を歌わせて」「ダメ」
何故かというと 大人たちは
この放置自転車の大半はお客さんなんだと
だからお客さんが減るようなことはできないし
どうしようと悩ましいんだ
中学生たちは 自分が訴えてることが
正しいと思ってますから
どうしたらいいんだろうって言って
子供と大人のバトルでした 最初は
でも ３回４回と通いながら ああでもない
こうでもないって言ってる内に
大人の方がだんだんだんだん
子供の方に根負けして行くんですよね
そこで いつの間にか子供と大人が対等に
アイデアを出し合って どうしたらいいやろう
何やったら中学生でも
やれることだろうって言って
協力し合って 結局彼女たちの発表は
更に工夫もされて
こんな発表やったんです
実はあるニュース番組を真似して
今日は放置自転車を無くそうと
取り組んでる中学生を取材しました
「では現地にいる何々さん」って言って
この動画を流したんですね
その動画の中で 彼女たちは
放置自転車を無くそうということをアピールする
メッセージを アーケードの中に
流れるBGMの合間合間に
自分たちの声で
入れさせてもらうということをしたんです
商店街の人たちも
「それやったら良いよ」って言って
BGMが１曲途切れたら 彼女たちの声で
長時間の駐輪をお止めくださいって
アナウンスが流れる
しばらくの間これは 続けられていて
今現在どうかは分かりませんけれども
彼女たちは ちょっとだけ自分たちが
社会貢献できたと思っていた
けれども 放置自転車はほとんど
無くならなかったって言って
笑って発表してました
だから 彼女たちのムーブメントっていうのは
成功したかと言われると
あまり効果がなかったっていうことで
終わるんですけれども
自分たちの思いを受けて 大人が変わってくれて
大人と一緒に 一つの
ムーブメントができたという喜びがあって
失敗を乗り越えながら
やっと達成できたことっていうことで
凄く喜んでたんです
こんなことができる中学生がいるんですよって
もう僕有頂天でした
もう 彼女たちもそれから
傘を作ったあの子たちも
自分の授業の中で
土曜日にも日曜日にも集まって
こんなこと作ってくれて
何回も商店街 行って交渉して
そしてやり遂げて
その上でしかも
「失敗やった　テへ」って笑って
自分で「アイアムオーケー」って言えている
そんな凄い子供たちがいるんですって言って
この発表をいろんな学校でさせていただいて
自分の手柄のようにやっていました
けれども一方で 実は
凄く大きな問題に直面し始めたんです
何かというと
これです
井口の授業は嫌だ 授業に行きたくない
とうとう 学校にも行きたくないって
言い出す子たちが出たんです
何故かというと 僕は事あるごとに
こういったことを発表してしまいましたので
子供たちの中では ちゃんと 何て言うのかな
プレゼンができないとダメ
しかも街中へ出ていって
自分の知らない人に喋りかけて
あるいはムーブメントもしなきゃいけない
みたいなことを言われていくと
僕にはできない
私は一人でコツコツはできるけど
グループの中で意見を言うなんて無理
まして発表なんてって言って
そのことがプレッシャーになって
学校に行き渋り始めちゃって
保護者の方からのクレームの嵐でした
だから「あ やっちまったな」と
どうしたら この僕の授業への拒否反応や
拒絶を乗り越えることができるだろうか
次の大きな問題に直面してしまいました
僕自身が「個性」そういった学びのスタイルが
多様になったと先ほど言ったにもかかわらず
そうした子供たちの個性を無視して
発表だけが大事
ムーブメントを
何かしなきゃいけないみたいなことだけを
言ってしまってたんだと思います
これが井口の暴力だったんだろうと思います
それに耐えかねた子供たちが とうとう
授業に対する拒否 拒絶をしちゃったんですね
それに直面した時 どうしようかと
本気で悩みました
答えは今でも見つかっていませんが
手掛かりになるような風景には時々会います
例えば この風景
僕のお気に入りの写真の一つです
僕が担任をしていた中学３年生の子たち
５月ごろに
学園祭の出し物を決めようって言うことで
昼休みに集まって話し合いをしていたんです
食堂に行って食べる子たち あるいは
ボール遊びをしたい子たちもいただろうに
皆でこうやって 机や椅子を全部どけてしまって
車座っていうか円形に座って
ワイワイガヤガヤと喋ってたんです
何やってんやろうって思って覗きに行った時に
この光景をみた時
慌ててカメラを取りに行って写真に収めた
ニヤニヤと笑いながら
この写真いいでしょうとか言って見てたんです
その時あることに気が付きました
この円形に座っているグループの
中にはいなかった 外側にいた子たちです
よく見ると この子たちこそが僕の授業では
拒否反応を示してた子たちだったんです
発表しにくい 誰かと
何て言うのかな
フレンドリーに喋るとか
コミュニケーションとるっていうのが
ちょっと苦手っていう子たちでした
で 教室では円形にこうやって座って
ああだこうだと どんな出し物するっていって
喋っているんですけれども
その輪の中に入ることを
拒否をしているわけではないんです
僕の授業に対する
拒絶なんかとは比べ物にならない
緩やかな 拒否反応で済んでるんですよね
で 何となく
このワイワイガヤガヤを遠目でみて
何となく一体感を持つ
何となく親近感を持つ
円の中に座っている子たちも
「入って来いよ」と強制しないんですね
そこでちきっと
聞いてくれているだろうという安心感
この子たちは 結局 学園祭では
裏方の音響係であるとか大道具係をして
クラスとしては大成功を収めました
この拒否ではない柔らかな一体感
緩やかな一体感
これが何故授業の中で
上手くできないんだろうか
こうした一体感を 授業の中で再現してみたい
いごこちが良いこと 居場所があること
安心できること
これが何故か教室の授業の時に
うまくできなかったんですね
アクティブラーニングと言われて
ミーティングだ あるいは
プレゼンテーションだって言われた時に
コミュニケーション能力がまだまだ
未熟だったり
あるいは個性として他者と誰かと
何かをするよりはどちらかというと
哲学的に自分の思考の中に
しっかり入って行きたい
みたいな子たちにとっては
オープンマインドっていうのは物凄く
居心地が悪いんですよね
皆さんの中にもスタバでだと
落ち着かないという人もいるかもしれません
僕らだったら ある意味では
周りに少し雑音があっても
自分の世界に入れるんですけれども
苦手な子っていうのはやっぱり
周りを囲ってあげた方が落ち着くんです
ちょっと動きが大きい子って
あの ビーズクッションって言われる
クッションがあると
そこにスポッと収まると 行動は落ち着いたり
ほっこりするんですね
そういったものが 授業の教室の中に
何故ないんだろう
我々は 従来の講義形式に戻して
今までこういった個性の違いとかいうのも
全部棚上げにしてきた時代に
戻ることはできないと思います
では どういうことが望まれるべきか
アクティブラーニングは
「開け開け」と言います
けれども僕はあえてそこに
「閉じろ閉じろ」と言いたいんです
開くと同時に 少しだけ閉じた空間を
教室の授業の中に作ってあげないとダメなんだ
円を作って座って喋っている
そういうグループを
ちょっとだけ離れた位置から緩やかに見守る
そういう空間を 授業の中で作ってあげたい
これはどうしたら良いか
建築の問題として考えるべきなんやろか
2010年に僕は中学校を移転させた
グループだったんですけれども
その建築を考える時にも 色々考えましたが
お金がかかっちゃうから 建築の問題として
これに取り組むというのは相当難しいです
では 家具やったら良いか
家具だと模様替えとかで雰囲気を
変えることができますが
非常に小さい
もうちょっと何かないかなって考えてる時に
学校建築の権威の ある建築家の先生から
次のようなことをアドバイス貰いました
「最近はね 建築っていうものと
家具というものの長所を合わせた
アーキファニチャーっていわれるような
考え方ができているんだよ」と
僕はもう すぐにこれに飛びつきました
で その建築家の先生にお願いをして
「どこか会社紹介して貰えませんか」
「是非このアーキファニチャーを
中学生と一緒に作りたい」って思ったんです
中学生と企業 そして
建築家と一緒にコラボしながら
学びのための空間として何が作れるか
今 それに取り掛かり
2020年にアクティブラーニングが
小中学校に導入されるのに合わせて
アーキファニチャーを販売できるペースで
やって行きたいと動きつつあります
あまり沢山のことはちょっと企業秘密なので
言えないですけれども
今現在 同志社中学校は このような一人分の机と
椅子を
整然とならべて黒板に向かっています
一般的な教室とよく似たものです
けれども こういう教室で例えば僕が授業で
「考えなさい」って言った瞬間に
子供たちは黙り込むんですね
僕が考えなさいって言われたら隣の人に
「お前どう思う？」って聞きたくなるんです
つまり考えるイコール喋るなんです僕の場合は
中には 考えるとなると自分で自分の世界に
ぐっと没頭できる子たちがいます
そういった考え方のスタイル自体も
バラバラなので
この教室のあり方っていうのは実は
教える側にとってのみ有効な教室なんですね
そこを現在は 廊下側だけはこれぐらいガバッと
開けるようにしたんですけれども
開く方向には どんどんどんどん進みました
でも一人分の机と椅子があるもんやから
完全には心開かない状態です
だから緊張感ばかりが教室の中に漂っちゃう
では教室ではない所に こうやって
リビングスペースみたいなものを作りました
畳を置いてちょっとぐらいは子供たちが
癒されるかなと期待して
ところが子供たちにとっては
授業の時間こそが緊張が高まってるので
教室の中に
これが欲しいっていうことになるわけです
僕らは教室は勉強の所
リビングはリビングって言って
分けちゃうんですね
でもそうじゃなかったんです
子供たちが
居場所がないって感じるのは授業中なんです
だから 授業の空間にこそ落ち着くような
リビングスペースが欲しいと
言い出してきたわけです
それをアーキファニチャーを使って
教室自体をアレンジしていく
そういった「開く」と「閉じる」を同時に
成立させるような
学校空間を作りたいと今思っているわけです
でもこんな 抽象的なことばかり言ってて
どんなもんなんだろうって
実は僕もそれはよく分かっていません
そこが中学生の醍醐味で
彼らは発想豊かにこうやったらいいん違う
例えばハンモックがあるといいよねとか
言い出してます
あるいは仲のいいお友達と２人で座れる
ベンチがあったらいいよね
映画館のあのカップル席みたいな感じで
言ってるような子たちまでいました
寝そべって授業を受けたい
あ なるほどな
そんなこと全部を叶えられるんだろうか
思いながら
でもちょっとチャレンジしています
今僕が一つだけ思っているのは この
アルネ・ヤコブセンという人のエッグチェア
これ最高のデザインだと僕は思っています
背もたれの部分が緩やかなカーブで
面白い形をしています
これを２〜３個あるいは４つ５つと
円形に並べるとこのような形になって
そもそもはホテルのロビーに置く椅子として
デザインされたんです
開かれた空間なんです
けれどもこれに座って数名で円形を作ると
この背もたれの部分のカーブが緩やかに
周りの人の視線を遮ってくれるんです
その結果 数人の人たちで
閉じた空間をオープンスペースの中に
いくつもいくつも
作れるような椅子なんですよね
このアルネ・ヤコブセンが提唱した
開くと同時に閉じるというようなことを
成立させるデザイン
これを学校空間の
しかも授業の場所に作ってみたい
開きながら閉じる
それを中学生と一緒に作ってみたい
そして 新たな価値や
新たな学校のスタイルというのを
発信できる新しいインフラとしての学校
あえて言えばカルチャー・インフラとしての
学校を中学生と一緒に作って行きたい
というのが今の僕の試みで
できれば2020年にまたこうした
舞台があれば
その商品を持ってこの場で
お話しできたらなと思っています
ありがとうございました
（拍手）